[Music]
it was a feast like Egypt had never seen
before the warrior gods set and his wife
the goddess neftis decorated an
extravagant Hall for the occasion with a
beautiful wooden chest as the
centerpiece they invited all the most
important gods
dozens of lesser deities and foreign
monarchs but no one caused as big a stir
as set and Nephi TSA's older brother
Osiris the God who ruled all of Egypt
and had brought prosperity to everyone
set announced a game whoever could fit
perfectly in the chest could have it as
a gift one by one the guests clambered
in but no one fit finally it was
Osiris's turn as he lay down everyone
could see it was a perfect fit another
win for the God who could do no wrong
then said slammed the lid down with
Osiris still inside sealed it shut and
tossed it into the Nile the chest was a
coffin
set had constructed it specifically to
trap his brother and planned the party
to lure him into it set had long been
jealous of his brother's successful
reign and hoped to replace him as the
ruler of all Egypt the Nile bore the
coffin out to sea and it drifted for
many days before washing ashore near
Biblos where a great cedar grew around
it the essence of the God within gave
the tree a divine aura and when the king
of byblos noticed it he ordered the tree
cut down and brought to his palace
unbeknownst to him the coffin containing
Egypt's most powerful God was still
inside
sets victory seemed complete but he
hadn't counted on his sister's sets wife
neftis was also his sister while their
other sister the goddess Isis was
married to their brother Osiris Isis was
determined to find Osiris and enlisted
Neff theses help behind SADS back the
two sisters took the shape of Falcons
and travelled far and wide some children
who had seen the coffin float by pointed
them to the palace of byblos Isis
adopted a new disguise and approached
the palace the Queen was so charmed by
the disguised goddess that she entrusted
her with nursing the baby Prince Isis
decided to make the child immortal by
bathing him in flame when the horrified
Queen came upon this scene Isis revealed
herself and demanded the tree when she
cut the coffin from the trunk and opened
it post Cyrus was dead inside weeping
she carried his body back to Egypt and
hid it in a swamp while she set off in
search of a means of resurrecting him
but while she was gone
said found the body and cut it into many
pieces scattering them throughout Egypt
Isis had lost Osiris for the second time
but she did not give up she searched all
over the land traveling in a boat of
papyrus one by one she tracked down the
parts of her husband's dismembered body
in every province of Egypt holding a
funeral for each piece at long last
she had recovered every piece but one
his penis which a fish in the Nile had
eaten
working with what she had Isis
reconstructed and revived her husband
but without his penis Osiris was
incomplete he could not remain among the
living could not return to his old
position as ruler of Egypt instead he
would have to rule over droite the realm
of the dead before he went though he and
Isis conceived a son to bear Osiris as
legacy and one day avenge him keep
exploring ancient Egypt with our guide
to the Egyptian underworld or follow
along with pesos yet as she checks in on
her patience during daily rounds
[Music]